[Music]
sometimes nah
all the time
almost on a daily i sit there and i
i think what's wrong with me
why can't i be like everyone else
why did i have to go through this
what i have to put up with this
the biggest one's my mom
it's the biggest resentment i have
i just don't understand
how the person who brought you into this
world
can just throw you away
you have kids
yeah i got uh i have six kids actually
six kids
were you around to raising
for
two of them i was around to raise them
my uh my seven-year-old daughter nevaeh
and my 12 year old son
nathan
i was there from the time he was 16
months until he was
about seven eight years old
then you were in prison for the rest
the prison was before that our prison
was before it was 26 years but it was
done in
it was done
13 years four years four years so on and
so forth 26 years in prison yeah what
was that for
um
well the first the first one was for uh
i got arrested for 22 council armed
robbery
and i received i received 12 years in
prison
but i ended up doing like 18 years
because of stuff i was doing in there
yeah what kind of stuff you do in prison
to keep your
keep you there
keep your credibility um stuff like that
i'm
just doing stabbings
stuff like that
yeah prison's every bit as violent as
outside of prison right
it's it's even more violent i think you
know
especially after living in this area
this is nothing
you know once once i've been through
prison this is
living out here is nothing
igrow where
um
i grew up
everywhere i guess i mean i never really
sat at one place very long
tell me about your family uh i don't
know my family
my uh
my mom gave me up when i was like six
years old and i haven't the next time i
seen her was when i was 35
and i haven't seen her since i was 35
and i'm 47 now so who raised him
foster care i was in foster care from
time i was six
until i got emancipated out at 18
and
i just been in and out of jail ever
since
no dad
no i never met my dad
well
so your teen years
you finished how far are you in school
i made it
i made it to about 11th grade
before i dropped out
you were in gangs too yeah i got i got i
got put into a gang out out in the city
orlando
and
about the time i was about 15 15 16
years old
and i started running with them
doing doing robberies
beating people up
um extorting neighborhood liquor stores
and stuff like that and this is a you're
are you mexican no i'm white so what
kind of gang it was a mexican gang
mexican gang yeah
but um
it landed me in prison you know
just that whole lifestyle
and then
when i went to prison i just
i just
followed suit just what the next what
the guy in front of me did i did the
same thing would you consider yourself
institutionalized
yeah
yeah i do
i've it was a lot worse for me when i
first got out
but um
it's getting it's getting better now but
i'm not the kind of guy that has that
passion to go out and look for work or
anything like that i've always been i've
always been about to hustle i've always
been about the next come up
you know stuff like that
um i did manage to uh when i was in
prison
pick up a particular trade that i use
out here and and
supplies my habits pays
pays for the things that i need
um i'm a fairly good tattoo artist
portrait artists and stuff like that
how do you support yourself now
just basically gr and like i said
hustling yeah
and drugs are part of your life
yeah
i've uh
i was on heroin for a long time but
i haven't been on heroin in probably
about eight years now
and
i now find myself drinking a lot
and
crystal meth
i started with the crystal meth because
i was a real bad alcoholic
i would drink blackout junk
and
i was introduced to crystal meth because
i was told that i could drink more
so that's why i started doing it and
then i ended up getting hooked on it
i'm being honest i don't even like it
but i can't stop
i just keep keep going and keep doing it
i tell myself every day i wake up i
don't want to do it no more
but i just keep doing it
sometimes during the day i find myself
out there looking for it
do you feel like the heroin or the
meth or the even the drinking
are just trying to distract you from the
pain you're feeling from like your
childhood or something
yeah
yeah
that's that's why the alcohol started
that's why the heroin started
and if you were to boil it down what do
you think the emotion is that you're
trying to numb from
the abandonment from my mother not
knowing my father
do you feel like you just weren't loved
yeah
i mean i can't say that i was in love
because i do know my grandma
my grandma she's passed away now
but
she always showed me love she took care
of me the whole time i was in prison
um first time i got out of prison i
lived with her
and
i knew what love was every time i was
around her
but to say
to say that i had it from my parents
i don't even know my parents
you know i've i've seen my mom a few
times
but it's just not the same yeah and
having a parent reject you like that
that's gotta impact your life forever
but yeah it impacted me so much that i
found myself looking for it
everywhere else you know whether it be
relationships or whatever how have your
relationships been with women since then
they haven't been good
i deal with a lot of uh
demeaning
factors i guess
like i i
treat women a certain way and i know
it's not right and i try not to treat
them that way
but then i always find myself like
sabotaging everything
because
my head tells me that
they're just going to leave anyway so i
might as well just push them away
and that's what i find myself doing
i've done it with everything in my life
so far
that's going to make it hard to
get anywhere and achieve anything in
life right
and you're you're your own worst enemy
yeah
it's like moments like this right now
the drink will be really good right
about now
have you ever talked with a therapist
about it or like that i've been in
therapy
from the time i was like
15
different places
and i'm not going to say that they
haven't worked
i just
i haven't allowed them to
really resonate with me and really work
i've constantly like i said just
push people away every time
it's that it's that lack of love that
just is
so hard to replace isn't it it's an
abandonment it's the rejections lack of
love like you said
um
i was even uh i was molested at a young
age and i was able to get over that i
mean that
that doesn't even render any bearing on
me anymore
you know i know that wasn't my fault you
know i was a child
but
for a long time it did like why is this
happening to me like
what do you think the biggest one is my
mom yeah
more than missing a dad
yeah
i just don't understand how
the one person who brought you into this
world
can just throw you away like you're
nothing
it caused me to grow up believing that
i'm nothing
anything anytime i do get something
i don't feel like i deserve it
you need to sabotage
yeah
hurt them before they hurt me so it
doesn't hurt so much
the cycle just continues and
never ends
yeah
i've tried
geographical i've tried everything and
it's just wherever i go
it just starts all over again
so i numb myself so i don't have to feel
it seems to be the one thing that works
even though i know it's destroying me
in your time in prison
was that
did he give you time to process and
think about everything you you
you've been through or are there drugs
in there as well
no there's there's drugs in there as
well and um
from
my first
what we'd like to say my first term
first second terms um
i was chasing i was chasing the drugs
that's why i i self-taught taught myself
how to draw
um
learn how to tattoo
it became very lucrative in there i i
made a lot of money at it and
all the money went towards my drugs
and supporting myself what little bit
that i did have
but on my last term i actually started
to do something better for myself
but even that ended up falling apart
i uh
i have about
nine to twelve i believe it is uh units
towards a psychology degree
from taking college courses in prison
i uh i have a couple trades under my
belt
but i don't have that passion or desire
to do anything with them
i would rather spend my day
locked in my room by myself
just drinking
you're depressed you describe yourself
as depressed severely depressed yeah and
that's been going on for how long
it's been going on for a while
[Music]
actually i think the depression started
probably right after the molestation
i
being that young i can't sit here and
say that i can pinpoint it to that
but now
at the age that i am now
i'd like to say that it started around
that time
i've never asked this
question before but what
how do you think how old were you when
that happened
i was uh i was eight years old and and
who did it to you the
foster dad yeah so how do you think that
impacts an eight-year-old boy
it took a lot of trust away from me like
i
i couldn't trust nobody after that
because with the things that he was
saying that he would hurt me if i told
anybody i couldn't tell nobody and then
whenever i did tell someone they didn't
believe me
did you know it was wrong at that age
no i i just
i like i said i was self-seeking i was
not self-seeking but i was i was seeking
love i was seeking
um
i wanted to be accepted i wanted to be
a part of you know i mean
and he just truly had me believing that
by doing this for him
i would i would get his love
but um
at that age you don't know that
you know you don't know things like that
maybe if i had
i had my my first wife she said
something to my son one time when he was
nine years old
she said you can't be mad at your dad
because he doesn't know how to be a dad
and it really messed me up when she said
that
but i processed it and i thought about
it
i was like no she's right
i never had a male figure in my life
that showed me what it meant
to be
a provider to be
that protector
i never had that so i never knew that
those were the things
that a man does those are the things
that a dad does
i mean i would play with my son and
play video games with them play with
them outside
i didn't know how to discipline them my
my
my
thought of disciplining was
you do what you told or
you're going to be
you're going to be spanked or you're
going to be
put in your room for the rest of the day
have your toys taken away or
but it was so
angry and aggressive the way that i
would get at my son
then my wife would tell me that's not
how you discipline
but i didn't know
i was never taught
i was taught that
something doesn't go your way you make
it go your way
47 years old i probably spent about 30
of my years
behind the walls
in one way or another
do you feel like you're angry as well
not as much as i used to be i just i
used to be so angry and
i didn't care who i hurt
i really didn't
you know whether it was physically or
emotionally or
i just didn't care
as long as it wasn't me getting hurt
but now i do
in my later in my later days here in my
as i get older
i come to notice that
carrying a lot carrying all that
anger and frustration and resentment and
all that
you're just hurting yourself
you're just hurting yourself you really
are
[Music]
sometimes nah
all the time
almost on a daily i sit there and i
i think what's wrong with me
why can't i be like everyone else
why did i have to go through this
why do i have to put up with this
the biggest one's my mom
it's the biggest resentment i have
i just don't understand
how the person who brought you into this
world
can just throw you away
i know i said that before but it's
that's the one that renders the most
pain
and you'll you'll take that pain to your
grave won't you
i heard this saying a while back and
says
you end up
becoming just like your parents
and i think i'll never be like my
parents because i don't even know my
parents
because i sit there and i think
i've abandoned my kids
i got hooked on drugs i went to prison
i'm just like my mom
a lot of my
defining factors for wanting to do
better was
just that in itself i don't want to be
like my
mom i have a lot of pain in it
i don't know how to get rid of it
all i know how to do is just
cover it up
not even deal with it
what are you afraid of now
i think the biggest thing that i'm
afraid of
is
[Music]
the biggest thing that i'm afraid of is
failure to be honest
i'm afraid to go out there and
make a better life for myself
because i'm
i'm scared to death and i'm gonna fail
one more time
and i just i can't see myself going
through it again
that's why i've just
i've i've become
like that chameleon
like i
living on these streets
it doesn't bother me
i can fit in anywhere
you know
i could put on a three-piece suit and
stand right next to a business owner i
can
i can break bread with a homeless guy
and feel the same way
i long to be accepted by one thing
or i just tell myself
i'm not going to be accepted by nothing
i want to change i just
i can't sit here i can't sit here and
say i don't know how to change
i don't know how to find the passion to
change
i wake up fully determined to do one
thing
and i find myself doing something else
all because somebody else who i want to
be friends with
said let's go do this
and i know
that's not what i want to do
but i'll go do it just to make them
happy
because i don't deserve to be happy
but if you ask my grandmother to tell
you different
you're seeing yourself in this situation
where you're addicted to drugs and
living in this
situation which is very similar to your
mom's
and you see how difficult it is for you
does that help you forgive your mom's
behavior
don't think it's helped me forgive as
much as it helps me relate
um
i don't think i'll ever forgive my mom
when
i said earlier that
i
my mom left me when i was six years old
and i seen her again when i was 35. i
went to prison when i was 18 i got out
when i was 35.
my mom was the one that picked me up
from the prison
she was
she was living with my grandma and
my grandma told her go pick me up and
she did
and i clearly remember her pulling over
on the side of the road
on the way home
and just break down crying
and i just looked looked at her like
it was the weirdest thing like where is
this coming from like
and she started telling me how
she's sorry for the life that i lived
and
i didn't understand what it meant
but she was a heroin addict and i was in
the way and i was stopping her from
doing what she wanted to do she never
wanted kids
and i just looked at her and
all i could say was
i don't want to hear this [ __ ]
take me home
like she was having a moment wanting to
ask for forgiveness and i just
i shot her down
i don't want to hear it
it is what it is
and a part of me was it's in the past
there's nothing you can do about it but
the biggest part was
i don't want to hear [ __ ] you got to say
you're angry
my anger
because you can understand that maybe
she came from
childhood where maybe she was
and she did
she was she was molested by her father
yeah by my grandfather there you go
and
so she has i mean she she has a lot of
anger too
but i haven't been around her since i
see her anger i haven't been around here
too like
i mean i remember the whoopings when i
was a kid
you know going out back and having to
pull my own switch and
get my ass put pretty bad
being locked in the room
sent to school with no shoes like i
remember those days
but to say that
she did them because she was
i
angry i can't say that i don't know why she
did it i
don't know if that's all she knew or
or like she said that day on the road
that
i got in the way
she never wanted kids
so maybe her way of raising me was i'm
just going to neglect them
i'm just going to treat them like [ __ ]
because i really don't want them
and i say them because i have a younger
brother
and uh
he got the better end of this he got the
better end of the deal
we both went through foster care and he
got uh
he got adopted
and now he's living a good life
i still talk to him every now and then
you got adopted by a better family he
had a
he got the better end of the deal
actually that's what caused me to uh
say something to
the there was a school nurse when i was
in elementary school that i told
about the molestation
and
the reason why is because
my little brother had told me that
dad was touching him
and that's why that's why i finally said
something
because i didn't want that to happen to
my little brother
you would think after everything that
i've been through
that i could
i could go through anything
but deep down inside i just feel like i
can't take no more
i just can't take no more
there's days i've had
thoughts of suicide and stuff like that
gone through therapy for it took classes
the thoughts are still there i don't act
on them i'll never act on them
but they're there
just thinking that i'd be a lot better
just
if i wasn't here
because i don't even understand why i'm
here
but i do know i'm here for a reason
i just don't know what it is
you still have hope
yeah i still have hope
i hope it ends soon
i'm sorry i said i hope it ends soon
i just thought
i don't mean to be
so down and negative
but just hearing
my life is
it just hit me it's like wow
but there's been good times in my life
yeah
yeah
my uh
july
july 31st 2015.
it's a day i'll never forget it's the
day i married my second wife
she uh
even to this day
we don't really talk no more
but um
if she was to call me right now i'd go
running in a heartbeat
she's
she's the owner of my heart i always
love her
she chose
to commit adultery and
my anger my pride
just like i'm not going to be treated
that way and
i could have worked it out with her i
loved her that much that i could have
overlooked it but
i didn't
i went out committed to crime and went
to prison and
when i got out of prison she was with
somebody else and
that's how the story goes
but we do have a beautiful
seven-year-old daughter together and
she loves the hell out of me
i love her too
but i managed to mess that up too as
well
behind my drugs
just really gotta grip them
because what do you say is the most
important
thing you've learned in your life
the most important thing that i've
learned in my life
[Music]
honestly
loyalty
that's the most important thing
finances doesn't mean nothing to me
um a roof over my head
those are all things that
a person
feels that it's a necessity
but you can still live without it
i've i've proven that with just my life
a lot of my friends they've proven it
with their lives
but if you don't have someone on your
side that you can be loyal to
and they can be loyal to you
you're gonna be alone
so i have to say that
loyalty
is probably the biggest thing i've
learned in my life
is to be loyal
that if you say something you honor it
you do it
no matter what the cost
or you just don't say it
and that's the way i live
i don't care if i've met you five
minutes or i've known you five years
if i say something to you it's it's done
it'll get to it'll it'll get done
i forget might take me a little bit but
it it'll get done
all right chris
thank you so much for sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck
thank you
he speaks so beautifully
listen to you all day long
you